hello and welcome to med simplified my
name is dr umar malik and in this video
i will tell you about top 10 health
benefits of flax seeds for centuries
flax seeds have been priced for their
health protective properties in fact
going back to the 8th century king
charles the great ordered his subjects
to eat flax seeds to improve their
health
so it's no wonder that flax seeds were
given the name linum ucitasimum
now 13 centuries later some experts say
we have preliminary research to pack up
what charles the great suspected
flax seeds are glossy brown in color and
are shaped like an apple pip which is
about four to seven millimeters long
the earliest evidence of humans using
wild flax was in the form of textiles
spun dyed and knotted wild flax fibers
were found in caves currently situated
in present-day republic of georgia
scientists estimate that these fibers
were dated to more than 10 000 years ago
today flaxseed is found in all kinds of
foods ranging from crackers to waffles
to oatmeal
flax seeds are emerging as a superfood
as more scientific research points to
their health benefits
so here are 10 health benefits of flax
seeds that are backed by science
number one flax seeds are loaded with
nutrients
flax has been grown since the beginning
of civilization and is one of the oldest
crops there are two types of flax seeds
brown and golden which are equally
nutritious
a typical serving size for grounded flax
seeds is 1 tbsp which is about 7 grams
just 1 tablespoon provides a good amount
of protein fiber and omega-3 fatty acids
in addition to being a rich source of
some key vitamins and minerals just to
look at how nutritious these seeds are
one tablespoon of flax seeds contains 37
calories 1.3 grams of protein 2 grams of
carbs and 1.9 grams of fiber
it also contains 3 grams of fat which
includes 1600 milligrams of omega-3
fatty acids
it contains some important vitamins like
vitamin b1 and vitamin b6 and folate it
also contains very important minerals
like calcium iron magnesium phosphorus
and potassium
interestingly flax seeds health benefits
are mainly attributed to the presence of
omega-3 fatty acids lignans and the
fiber present in them
now let's talk about the number second
important health benefit of flax seeds
which is the presence of high amounts of
omega-3 fats in them flax seeds are a
rich source of alpha-linolenic acid ala
which is plant-based omega-3 fatty acid
ala is one of the two essential fatty
acids that you have to obtain from the
food you eat as your body doesn't
produce them
animal studies have shown that the ala
in flax seeds prevented cholesterol from
being deposited in the blood vessels of
the heart reduced inflammation in the
arteries and reduced tumor growth
a costa rican study involving
3638 people found that those who ate
more ala had a lower risk of heart
attack than those who consumed less
amount of ala
also a large review of 27 studies
involving more than 250 000 people found
that ala was linked to a 14 lower risk
of heart attacks
numerous studies have also linked ala to
a lower risk of stroke so if you're a
vegetarian or you don't eat fish flax
seeds can be your best source of omega-3
fats and ala
it will not only boost your heart health
but will also prevent chronic damage to
your blood vessels from toxins
prevent stroke and tumor growth
number three flax seeds are a rich
source of lignans which may reduce
cancer risk
lignins are plant compounds that have
antioxidant and estrogenic properties
both of which can help lower the risk of
cancer and improve health
interestingly flax seeds are one of the
richest sources of lignans and contains
up to 800 times more lignans than other
plant foods
observational studies show that those
who eat flax seeds have a lower risk of
breast cancer particularly in females
beyond 50 or those who are
post-menopausal additionally according
to a canadian study involving more than
6 000 females those who ate flax seeds
were 18 percent less likely to develop
breast cancer
men can also benefit from eating flax
seeds in a small study men who were
given 30 grams of flax seeds a day while
following a low fat diet showed reduced
levels of a prostate cancer marker
suggesting a lower risk of prostate
cancer
flax seeds have appeared to have the
potential to prevent colon and skin
cancer in labs and animal studies yet
more research is needed to confirm this
nevertheless the evidence thus far
points to flax seeds being a potentially
valuable food in the fight against
various cancers
number four flax seeds are rich in
dietary fiber
just one tablespoon of flax seeds
contains three grams of fiber which is
eight to 12 percent of the daily
recommended intake
flax seeds contain two types of dietary
fiber soluble dietary fiber and
insoluble dietary fiber the fiber gets
fermented by the bacteria in the large
bowl this bulks up the stools and
results in more regular bowel movements
on one hand the soluble fiber increases
the consistency of the contents of your
intestine and slows down the digestion
rate
this has been shown to definitely help
in regulating blood sugar levels and
decreasing cholesterol levels
similarly on the other hand the
insoluble fiber allows more water to
bind to the stools which increases their
bulk and results in softer stools this
is especially useful for preventing
constipation and relieves symptoms for
those who suffer from irritable bowel
syndrome or diverticular disease
number fifth health benefit of flax
seeds is that they help to lower blood
cholesterol levels
in one study people with high blood
cholesterol levels were selected and
half of the people were given 30 grams
of flaxseed powder daily for 3 months
when compared to the ones who didn't
consume flax seed powder the total
cholesterol levels lowered by 17 percent
and bad ldl cholesterol levels lowered
by almost 20 percent
in another study of people with diabetes
researchers found that taking 10 grams
of flaxseed powder daily for one month
resulted in a 12 increase in good hdl
cholesterol levels
these effects appear to be due to the
fiber present in flax seeds as it binds
to the bile salts and is then excreted
by the body to replenish these biosols
cholesterol is pulled from your blood
into your liver this process eventually
lowers your blood cholesterol levels
number six flax seeds may help to lower
blood pressure levels
studies on flax seeds have also focused
on its natural ability to lower blood
pressure a canadian study found that
eating 30 grams of flax seeds daily for
six months lowered systolic and
diastolic blood pressure by 10
millimeters and 7 millimeters of mercury
respectively for those who are already
taking blood pressure medication flax
seeds lowered blood pressure even
further it was also seen that regular
flax seed consumption decreased the
number of patients with uncontrolled
high blood pressure levels by more than
17 percent
furthermore according to the large
review that looked at data from 11
studies revealed that taking flax seeds
daily for more than 3 months lowered
blood pressure levels by 2 millimeters
mercury
you may feel that this 2 millimeter
mercury fall is insignificant but a 2
millimeter mercury reduction in blood
pressure can lower the risk of dying
from stroke by 10
and from heart disease by more than 7
percent
number 7 flax seeds contain high quality
protein
flax seeds are a great source of
plant-based protein and there is growing
interest in flaxseed protein and its
health benefits flaxseed protein is rich
in amino acids such as arginine aspartic
acid and glutamic acid numerous lab and
animal studies have shown that flaxseed
protein helped to improve immune
function lowered cholesterol prevented
tumors and had anti-fungal properties
also
if you are considering cutting back on
meat and worried that you will go hungry
flax seeds may be just your answer in
fact in one study 21 adults were given
an animal protein or plant protein meal
the study found no difference in terms
of appetite satiety or food intake noted
between the two meals the likely
explanation is that both the animal and
plant protein meals stimulate hormones
in the gut to bring about the feeling of
fullness which eventually results in
eating less also known as early satiety
number eight flax seeds can also help to
control blood sugar levels
type 2 diabetes is a major health
problem worldwide millions of people are
suffering from uncontrolled sugar levels
and eventual complications that develop
type 2 diabetes is characterized by high
blood sugar levels as a result of either
the bodies inability to secrete insulin
or the body becoming resistant to it
a few studies have found that people
with type 2 diabetes who added 10 to 20
grams of flaxseed powder to their daily
diet for at least one month saw
reductions of 8 to 20 percent in their
blood sugar levels
this blood sugar lowering effect is
notably due to the flax seeds insoluble
fiber content
researchers have found that insoluble
fiber slows down the release of sugar
into the blood and reduces blood sugar
levels
however one study found no change in
blood sugar levels or any improvement in
diabetes management
even though more research is still
needed and results are confusing flax
seeds can be a beneficial and nutritious
addition to the diet of people with
diabetes
if you'd like to know more about the
best diet for diabetes click the banner
above to watch our video i will also
provide a link in the description box
down below
number nine health benefit of flax seed
is that they can decrease hunger which
can aid in weight control
now if you have the tendency to snack
between meals you should consider trying
flax seeds as they are great for
munching and are very effective in
reducing hunger pangs
one study found that adding 2.5 grams of
flax fiber extract to a beverage reduce
the feelings of hunger and overall
appetite
the feelings of reduced hunger were
likely due to the soluble fiber content
of flax seeds
the fiber in flax seeds slows digestion
in the stomach which triggers a host of
hormones that control appetite and
provide a feeling of fullness
flax seeds dietary fiber can help in
weight control by suppressing hunger and
increasing the feelings of fullness
this is especially useful in diabetic
and hypertensive patients who are
actively trying to lose weight by
controlling their appetite naturally
number 10 flax seeds are a versatile
ingredient
flax seeds or flaxseed oil can be added
to many common foods you can try the
following methods to make the most out
of flax seeds adding them to water and
drinking it as a part of your daily
fluid intake
drizzling flaxseed oil as a dressing on
salad
sprinkling grounded flax seeds over your
breakfast cereal
mixing them into your favorite yogurt
adding them into cookies muffins breads
or other batters
mixing them into smoothies to thicken up
the consistency
and incorporating them into meat patties
remember to always opt for grounded flax
seeds as they are easier to digest whole
flax seeds are not useful because your
intestines cannot break down the tough
outer shell of the seeds that being said
you can still buy whole flax seeds grind
them in a coffee grinder and store the
grounded flax seeds in an airtight
container
with many proven health benefits and
possibly more there is no better time
than now to grab some flax seeds from
your local grocery store or you can also
buy them online by clicking the links in
the description box down below
thank you so much for watching this
video and i hope you liked it to support
us become a member of our mid-simplified
youtube channel or support us via
patreon do comment below about any
feedback you would like us to know so
friends take care and see you in our
next video